and when i became a binge drinker my
life was literally broken down into how
many binges did i have that year
what does a loved one do to help that
person
transition out and be free so when a
person says my husband is
choosing to drink over our relationship
you have to eliminate that from your
thought process because
the people who've gone through addiction
this is not a choice
nobody is asked for this to happen this
is not
his fault we're driving home and he says
hey pat how come you're not saying
anything to me i said you know just to
be honest with me i just see you being
in pain
and i hope you realize there's value to
life i don't know how to
help you that is the best and most
honest and supportive thing you can do
to a loved one who's suffering
is alcohol adversely affecting
any part of your life if the answer is
yes
then you need to address it
my guest today is claudia christian
which by the way if you
if you go in there and do research on
her story as an actress and what she's
done in the life you've
she's lived you will be so curious on
what we can learn from her because she
did a tedx talk
a few years ago i don't know if it was
two years ago three years ago
on how she dealt openly she came out and
talked about how she dealt with
uh aud and how she relapsed 20 times and
how
she even went and tried a lot of
different programs and even once you
spent thirty thousand dollars on a
program and
this is very close to me because i've
dealt with uh
many close friends and family of mine
who have struggled with this but prior
to
getting into the interview let me just
read to you what her book
babylon confidential a memoir of love
sex and addiction
how it describes her life then you're
gonna see where we're gonna go with this
so from the set of dallas to her
starring role on the sci-fi series
babylon 5
claudia's affairs with billionaires
supermodels rock stars and celebrities
are mixed with shooting stalking
heartbreak and betrayal onset and off
drama follows claudia an alcohol feud
fuel coke run and make out session with
a bridesmaid on her wedding day her
attempt tempest her love-hate
relationship with actor agnes mcfaden
the conspiracy theory surrounding her
ex-husband
and uh her relationship with billionaire
dottie fight who's from egypt middle
eastern
before he dated princess diana hollywood
life takes on a toll on claudia she
descends into alcohol addiction
and desperate battle to reclaim her life
the reason why i'm reading this is
because i asked permission before i read
this
i spent going article after article
after article
and i think who we have today is
somebody that can save many people's
lives
every year a hundred thousand people in
america died due to alcoholism worldwide
three million
and that's a real number that's 5.3
percent
of all cause of death around the world
every year is due to alcoholism
and she's doing something about it with
that being said claudia thank you so
much for being a guest on valuetainment
it is my absolute pleasure thank you yes
and and i appreciate you
going out there you know talking about
it years ago
when uh who was it i think it was gerald
ford's uh
wife when she came out and she used to
be betty ford when it was very much of a
a secret thing that nobody would talk
about and
she has a facility in in uh palm desert
i think it's in palm desert or indian
wells
and uh people swear by it so for you to
be able to do that i know it's been a
a positive impact in many other people's
lives but before we go into that why
don't we kind of go into your story
because your story is so
so many different angles we can go with
your story so before anything i'll just
let you tell us
uh claudia if i was in high school with
you
and we were 14 years old yes if i'm
sitting next to you in high school
and i'm classmates with you who was
claudia
in high school claudia in high school
was
a 45 year old trapped in a 14 year old's
body desperate to get out of high school
she took extra courses worked five jobs
uh sold sports equipment worked in a
cafe getting her butt pinched by the
manager just to make enough money to
move the hell out of how the house and
become an actress in la
so my impetus as as a 14 year old uh
my virginity at 14 had just been taken
by
a molester uh who lived next door to us
we moved to a new high school so i was
15 in a new high school and away from
that rapist
so i was in probably a very vulnerable
position but i was extremely
focused and a very tough kid so i really
never dealt with that
trauma i went straight into the next
school and my plan was to get out as
soon as possible i had an amazing
guidance counselor
who got me a scholarship and got me
enough credits to graduate with a ged by
the time i was 16 and a half years old
when i moved to los angeles
so if you had met me in high school i
wanted nothing to do with anybody i
wanted to get
out i didn't want anything to do with a
high school experience i was an adult
i had a checking account i had a plan i
wanted to be on tv
and i was focused as hell when did that
happen when did you know what you wanted
to do
very very young in life i um i did some
theater as a
as a little child and i was very shy i
had tinnitus i had
difficulties with my hearing and i
remember being on stage and everything
disappeared
and i was focused and i was i felt that
i could move people
i was a really highly sensitive child so
when i saw people listening
or laughing or even shedding a tear
when during the production i was i was
really that was it for me
i thought well i can communicate this
way with people
um so i fell in love with performing as
a child
and then subsequently really didn't know
how that would transform my life or how
i would get into it and then we were
transferred to california and i thought
well this is god's plan
to put me near los angeles because it
wasn't going to happen in westport
connecticut
but uh yeah so and then that sounds very
myopic and
kind of uh conceited but but you know
children don't have that
um in general don't have that fear of
failure all i knew
was this is what i wanted to do so i'm
going to make it happen
and i you know i i think that's probably
why i succeeded
is because i didn't really know i could
fail
you know this was my dream and i wanted
to do it
amazing and wasn't wasn't uh marilyn
monroe also known as being highly
sensitive as well like
she could you know she would move and
feel and you know
respond to all the different reactions
people were having do you
do you see that as a common trait with
those who become
very good actors and actresses i think
that a lot of artists
are empaths and that we absorb pain from
other people and we can sense when
someone is uncomfortable i mean we can
read people
so i would agree that i a lot of my my
actor friends and writer friends are
very sensitive people
um does that necessarily equate to being
a good actor
no not necessarily but um it's it
definitely
tends to also make you take a lot on
and i and i think artists are drawn to
that we have pain and
you know this is an expression of our
our need to communicate our need to show
our pain so it's
it's quite exquisite when you get a role
for instance that you can dive into that
that madness or that shame or something
because it's cathartic
so so this is almost therapy um
you know it's when you get a really good
role it's it's therapeutic on a daily
basis
so when you left at 16 and you're
deciding to
go pursue your dreams and be an actress
yourself
you know when what when did you land
something when you said i think i think
i'm in this thing now
which one was it when you're like i
think i think this could lead into a
real career
i i was so fortunate i met a manager and
i
talked her into signing me for a
three-year deal
um i did all these things which used to
be called in the industry go sees
back in the old days the 80s the casting
directors would see
new actresses and have take meetings
with them to see if they could cast them
in the future so i was
lucky i made the rounds in in los
angeles through the work of this manager
and eventually when i turned 18 because
i looked much older i was very tall i
had a deep voice still even then
um so i had to wait till i was 18 to
play you know 18.
um yeah second i turned 18 i had a job
lined up on dallas
i mean five and under and then the next
thing i had falcon crest and then i had
a tv series called behringers by the
time i was 18 i was making six figures
wow it happened yeah and i mean dallas
for everybody to you know i remember
watching dallas when we were in germany
and dallas was like if you're on dallas
everybody follow dallas
how would you compare what dallas is
today because
everybody in the world was following
dallas it's like
it's as iconic as friends or seinfeld i
mean everybody watched
dallas everybody it was riveted to it i
had a very small
scene but it was the top of its game i
mean larry hagman directed it it was the
very first television show i ever did
so you know the catering was was it was
amazing you know it was like steak and
lobster i mean everything was
to start there uh was kind of rough
because subsequently over the years
doing
indie films in in uh you know in in
eastern european countries and so forth
you know you have to get you have to
sort of take take uh
take everything with a grain of salt and
know that nothing would be quite that
glamorous as that first job
out of all the work you did and all the
different kinds of movies you did
what what format was your favorite was
it more
doing the uh two hour feature where
you're going out you're gonna be with
your team for a while was it more the
sitcoms where you're kind of going in
and
uh how that format was was it more the
independent film side which one was your
favorite when you got a job you're like
i'm excited about this one here
i was always excited to get a studio
film or something but to be honest with
you
i love being on a series because it's it
becomes your family
and and it's it gives your life
structure
you don't you're not looking for a job
anymore you're you're
you're home you know you know where
you're going to work this day this day
of that week
you've got your script you have you fall
in love with your character you work on
your correct
character you develop it through the
seasons so for me
siri's work has always been the most
gratifying and but i mean i'm i'm a
person who
who likes that regular work um
you know and it's it's it's i'm i've
done a lot of television so i think
that's
my my wheelhouse my you know i'm
not not to say that i didn't love doing
a movie of the week or a feature and
going to
you know some place and shooting a film
it was marvelous get to know people and
you're out in a month
or a 45-day shoot or a 20-day shoot yeah
that's fun too
then i like i like coming home every day
to the same crew
the same makeup artist you know shooting
the breeze
with the same people because it really
does i'm still friends with people that
i did series with in the 90s
because we became so close pre-cell
phone days of course
cell phone days it's free sales people
talk
days where we were free because now you
have to stay on top of everything
everything's being documented today so
whatever you're doing there's
330 million cameras around you non-stop
recording everything you're doing it's a
different time we're living in
let me tell you how grateful i am that i
didn't have the worst of my alcohol
problem
nowadays where there's a camera on you
everywhere because
people would have shame shame inducing
video on me i'm sure
because you know but luckily i didn't
they didn't have smartphones when i was
really suffering
so that's something i think about a lot
because it's such an invasion to people
who are suffering right now
we don't need to see a picture of them
walking into the rehab facility it's
really not our business
you know and everything is so public now
and and seeing people
you know coming out of surgery or out of
hospital or out of detox
it's really unfair it's such an invasion
and it's just normal now we
we make we make fun of people going into
into treatment you know with late night
comedians sit there and say oh it's the
eighth time they've gone in that's not
funny
it's not funny they're dying they're
suffering you know you
you wouldn't laugh at people who have
eight rounds of chemo
you know but we laugh at people who
consistently
seek treatment and it's not it's really
not funny
and it's because it's so public and it's
so it's so um
acceptable to shame people nowadays with
photos video
with with articles i totally agree with
you i totally agree with you and it's
um i mean i go back to the army and i
think about myself when guys say so pat
you know you you don't
drink a lot how come you're not a guy
that drinks you know i'll have an
old-fashioned every other week if i'm
sitting with somebody and i'll have a
cigar
with a friend or something like that but
in the army let me tell you i was
competing i was trying to see if i can
finish all the jack and coke in the
world and see if i can do it all by
myself and i was hanging out with jose
on friday night and saturday for two and
a half years straight
and uh in my family in the middle east
growing up in iran alcohol was like a
cool thing you drank because you were
cool and everybody was doing it and then
eventually you saw
how it uh took some people's lives
personal lives their sanity their
freedoms and some couldn't even drop it
you know i can't tell you how many times
i've gone
to friends uh where the first time even
when i was going through it with one of
my friends he couldn't stop drinking
alcohol i said why don't you just quit
what's the big deal right you kind of
say comments like that you don't know
their pain
so eventually one of my friends who was
going through a bad i was at the prison
to pick him up i'm sitting outside three
o'clock in the morning
finally he gets out gets in the car this
was like his fourth or fifth dui
and we're driving home and i don't say
anything to him
and he says uh hey pat how come you're
not saying anything to me i said i said
you know just to be honest with me i
just see you being in pain
i just want to see you get out of this
thing i don't know what you're going
through but you're in pain
and i hope you realize there's value to
life i don't know how to help you
i don't have a method the only thing i
know is what i've seen others go through
whether it's
aaa and all these other programs but uh
i hope you figure out a way to get
through this and eventually he figured
out a way to get through it and he's
doing great he's changed his life
you know in a completely different way
but many people don't get to that point
yeah but what you said to him people
should be aware of that that is
love and support and what most people do
is say why can't you just stop well
ask somebody why can't you stop
breathing when you have a compulsive
disorder of the brain
it's not logical why would i put a
poison in my body that is ruining my
life
that's not logical so to tell me to stop
is not
doesn't make sense clearly there's
something wrong with my brother
i've learned this compulsive disorder so
for you to say to your friend
you know i see that you're in pain and i
just want to support you
that is that is the best and most honest
and supportive thing you can do to a
loved one who's suffering
that is that is wonderful and you did
and you were honest you didn't know how
to help him
but you were there as a friend you
picked him up you didn't shame him you
didn't judge him that's wonderful
what claudio what was that movie where
the husband his wife was an alcoholic
and she couldn't help himself and the
husband was a sweet husband
and she kept relapsing meg ryan
andy garcia is it meg ryan and when a
man
anybody who's suffered through alcohol
use disorder we'll know that
we'll know those little signs no it's
very sad because
most people are shared that this this
all they know is the 12-step world
and because that is what is
predominantly used despite the fact
that alcohol deaths are increasing cobit
has seen a massive uptick of alcohol use
disorders especially amongst women
we still lose 100 000 people a day three
and a half million in the world every
year
it still costs the u.s 225 billion
dollars a year
alcohol misuse and we're still using
this antiquated peer support
which is not a medical treatment even
though we sex
six medicines that address alcohol use
disorder
so when people say you know well i don't
just go to a meeting
or do this or just quit or just say no
it's flying in the face of everything we
know about addiction which it is it is
not something you can control or be
mindful or will power your way through
it or white knuckle your way through
it a very small percentage of
individuals in the world can quit
anything on their own
that's about eight percent of the
population and if you look at the
success rates of 12-step programs
it's about less than five percent but
the really sad
statistic is that only 10 of people
suffering from an alcohol use disorder
seek treatment
and out of that 10 out of those 10
percent of the people
only one will have any form of long-term
success
out of 10 only one will have success
yes and that means 90 of people who are
suffering right now aren't going to seek
treatment and you know why they're not
going to seek treatment
been told that all they can do is quit
and go to meetings for the rest of their
life
and that doesn't appeal to a 30 year old
or a 20 year old
or anybody i mean the majority of people
they want their life back they don't
want to be told
that this is what they have to do and
they don't want to live with cravings
for the rest of their life
claudia do you mind sharing with the
audience uh how
it happened because the way you
described in my 20s it was just what in
my 30s little into my 40s i'm like i'm
the last guy
can you kind of go through your
experience how that happened to you sure
it is a learned behavior so so most
people don't just
go to a bar and have a drink and
suddenly they're addicted to alcohol
and it's clearly not a choice you don't
say well i want to wake up and be an
alcoholic
so what happens is if you have the
genetic predisposition and you engage in
the behavior
you have a higher chance of of
developing an alcohol use disorder over
time
especially if you start drinking before
your brain is fully developed
around your early 20s so here we have me
i'm drinking in my 20s
very lightly i mean for my like for me
to split a bottle of wine with somebody
was a big
saturday night of drinking that's two
glasses i mean then that was like wow
i've had enough
so i was normal and then in my 30s i was
normal until my late 30s i still it
started escalating
i was hanging around with a lot of wine
collectors you know it was that time of
uh in society when people were smoking
cigars and drinking wine and
and you know it was it was very
acceptable i had a lot of friends who
you would now call
partiers i had a wine collection and it
escalated from a couple times
a month to a couple times a week to now
four day four nights a week
i was drinking too much and so it was
brought to my attention by a boyfriend
and also by family members you know
we think you're drinking too much so i
quit which is logically the thing you're
supposed to do
right you're supposed to quit drinking
when you're drinking too much
but what i didn't know is that causes
what's known as the alcohol deprivation
effect
so your brain is now deprived of
something you've been feeding it on a
regular basis your neural pathways are
engorged it's used to getting ethanol
on a certain regular pattern and now
it's not getting it so what does it do
first month or so you're fine you know
you're
saying well i feel great at being sober
this is something that can work
then the cravings start coming in the
thoughts about alcohol
you know you see your friend drinking
you smell it you you see a movie where
someone's drinking red wine or whatever
then you start physically craving like
now you can't get it off your mind and
you're
you're uncomfortable in your skin so you
say to yourself well i've been sober for
two months
i don't have a problem and you have a
drink that's what this little trickster
in your brain tells you
you're fine you've been sober for two
months you don't have an alcohol problem
have one and then that one turns into
you coming home with a bottle two nights
later and that comes into you
opening up your wine cellar again that's
what happened to me
and now drinking heavier than you did
before
so i went from being a light drinker to
a social drinker to a heavier drinker to
a binge drinker
and when i became a binge drinker at
that point in my late
30s my life was broken down until i
found the sinclair method in 2009 my
life was literally broken down into how
many binges did i have that year
how long did i manage to have sobriety
and so that is not a pleasant place to
live
because while you're sober you're
craving while you're binging you're
miserable
so claudia let me ask you this i see two
things here
one i see the the the if we
if we're running a company you want to
get to the deepest issue the deepest
issue is what started it
and then once you're in too deep then
how do you address it at that point so
let's go back to
the start the how it got started and
then we're going to the deeper issue
so so social light heavy binge social
life heavy binge
when you started going through the phase
of collecting the wines and you got your
own collection and partiers and all this
stuff
how much of it was due to association
how much of it was due to industry and
how much of it was it because
you're a star you're on tv you're
everywhere you're making money your
lifestyle's different so there are
certain things that comes
with hey i'm making money and let me
kind of uh this is what
rich people do and the reason why i ask
this is because you know most of our
audience
they're entrepreneurs they're business
people so these are folks that are also
experienced in the same thing you start
off early
then you got a little bit of success
then you got some neighbors
they got some newer things so how do you
think most
people who get into this and get
addicted how do you think that habit
begins
i well i believe it you just nailed it
it's a habit so
what happens is you you start partying
with your friends but
you notice that your friends stop and
switch to coffee
at 11 o'clock at night or maybe your
friend goes no you know what i've had
enough i'm gonna have a glass of water
but you you don't stop i was the last
girl at the bar going come on let's have
zambooka shots at this point
i didn't know what an end was and end
was
me just going to bed and so that's not
normal but nobody in those days pointed
out you know
hey claudia we've all stopped drinking
now
you don't need another drink because
nobody really noticed it was just
she's the girl who keeps drinking and
there's always another guy who keeps
drinking see then i'm drinking with that
guy
it wasn't like i was the only one that
didn't have an off button
so so that it normalizes it and now of
course
hindsight is always clearer i it's
completely
not normal to drink four nights a week
two bottles of wine that's not normal
use of alcohol
that's just not normal especially alone
drinking alone
well then you can justify it and say
well i i'm a wine connoisseur or
you know this is what they do in europe
well no it's not what they do in europe
in europe they have small glasses of
wine with meal
you know in america we have these large
pours of
you know of of wine and we for every
occasion
for a baby shower for this for that
there's alcohol everywhere in the united
states
always you know we call england in
australia drinking cultures
we are a drinking culture so for me
it didn't seem like it was terribly
obvious until somebody said to me you
know you drink really quickly
now mind you this is coming from a
boyfriend i'm dating who drinks a ton
himself
so once again the defensiveness of
somebody's saying well
wait a minute you're drinking as much as
i am right and he's saying well yeah but
i drink slower than you and i'm bigger
than you
and you you keep up with me and it's
it's kind of weird i've never seen a
woman drink as much as you and i'm like
well i have a big tolerance i'm irish
and german
you know all of these things right when
you're in it
there's no way you can look outside
yourself and say oh that's the hallmark
of alcoholism
claudia you need help you know you don't
you you're defensive you're justifying
it
you know i can look back now and say wow
okay there were clear signs but
of course you don't see them yourself
that's where people are right now
the thing i ask people is this is
alcohol
adversely affecting any part of your
life
that can mean anything from your
relationships to working out in the
morning
is it affecting adversely affecting any
part of your life if the answer is
yes then you need to address it
if it's affecting your work your health
your family anything
if you have lots of fights with your
loved one you've got to look at what
you're
consuming and how much and and how is it
serving you how is alcohol serving you
if you don't ask yourself
questions you're never going to be able
to identify if you have a problem or not
the challenge is you know if you're
aware of it when you're in it so
let me let me ask a different question
from you since this is your world that
you've spent a lot of time studying you
said
20 times relapsing and you tried every
single method
that you went through even some of the
methods you went through where one of
them was shaming you and they finally
gave you the medicine like i can't wait
to get the hell out of here you
eventually leave so
you know the different formats and what
people are saying the question becomes
the following
how much uh like when i look at uh
my my personality my wiring i'm very
obsessive i know my wiring like i know
i have to sit in a certain place if i go
to a restaurant and if i don't sit there
i'm not gonna eat at the restaurant i
leave that's my y ring i can't help
myself i've been like this
since uh since i was a uh kid so
how much of how much of the individual
getting addicted has to do with
them as their personality and wiring how
much of it is an
upbringing and how much of it is
escaping
reality so so dna upbringing
escaping reality i think genetics play
a big part of it but to give you an
example um out of three siblings
in my family two became a addict and one
did not
so how do you explain we have the same
genetics
and one escaped it was it because
he's stronger or has more willpower or
is it because he didn't
actually get that particular gene
or is it because he was so busy with his
particular line of work
that he could not engage in drinking as
much as i did
so he didn't develop an alcohol use
disorder this is the engineer
this is the engineer yeah so so so
you have two siblings with the same
child sort of the same childhood they're
older than me so they had different
experiences and i left home earlier
but a similar upbringing and similar
genetics
my belief is definitely that socio
influences
are huge okay also trauma my brothers
weren't raped
you know but one of my brothers watched
my other brother die
that's major trauma wow major trauma
the third sibling perhaps didn't have as
much trauma
who knows you know i mean so so you have
you have somebody who witnessed a death
at a very young age you have somebody
who was molested at a very young age and
then you have somebody who
had you know a rough time with his
interpersonal relationships
within his family but didn't have that
kind of
that raw trauma so maybe that's why he
dodged the bullet i don't know this is
something that i've certainly been
observant and i always ask people
by the way speaking of your your
obsessive need to sit places
it's interesting because people with ocd
and eating disorders quite often do
develop a substance use disorder as well
because it is their way to control the
circumstances
they cannot control what's going on in
their life so they self-medicate or they
purge or they starve themselves in order
to control
their surroundings now it's a very easy
thing to say oh that person drank
because they
they lived through a war ptsd
yes absolutely trauma yes absolutely
people do self-medicate for those
reasons but it's about that cut and dry
there are people who are biological
addicts meaning that they
simply have the genetics they engaged in
the behavior and now they're addicted
now i always search for something more
but quite honestly i've met people who
once they take this
they use this method and they get rid of
the biological issue
they're they're pretty good i mean they
move on in their life they used to have
a drinking issue they're not
self-medicating for trauma or anything
like that um but
but you know each individual is
different every single person drinks for
a different reason and they're wired
differently so you can't
there's no one fixed treatment for every
single person and i'm not here to
espouse one treatment or say
that this doesn't sure of course i'm a
firm believer in whatever works for you
is the right method for you the only
thing for me it's it's just what
triggers it that that's what i'm curious
about is there is there a
vision of things i mean right it's also
it's also the
every time you drink you are learning
the behavior your neural pathways become
more and more engorged and wider and
wider and bigger and bigger
until they're super highways and now
you're physically dependent on alcohol
that's the course so you've got people
walking around with little country roads
for neural pathways and when they take a
drink
they don't get that massive endorphin
reinforcement
that alcoholics do yeah so of course you
don't want to stop
drinking because it feels so good some
people
take a drink of alcohol and they go i
don't know what the big deal is
i don't i mean i like the taste of beer
but i don't i don't
they don't get a reinforcement they
don't get the reward
that addicts do that makes sense
of course it does of course it does so
but i know your father i believe your
father was a
surgeon but was was your father a
surgeon no
no that's wrong on wikipedia or wherever
the hell that is on
that was some somebody put
misinformation out there no
my grandfather was a surgeon and a
cancer researcher um
and i have a lot of doctors in my uh
family but my father was
uh with shallow oil company actually uh
for
the majority of his career he was in oil
business
how about your mom my mother was in
retail and
uh fashion her whole life
um uh and had her own store and worked
at giorgio's and beverly hills and
very successful in that world very into
clothes and
so forth um so home was pretty stable
your your home was pretty stable where
you were
my home wasn't stable at all when i was
eight years old my brother was killed
i mean that that doesn't and it resulted
in my parents
divorce i mean uh you know so that
fractured our family
intensely plus we moved around all the
time my dad
transferred constantly so i had no you
know friends
i had was always the new girl uh you
know and there was um
you know i i lost my father last year
and i loved him to pieces but he was a
and he will admit it he was a tough
tough father
and there was no love lost between my
parents there were you know
affairs and so forth so it's it's it was
not an idyllic childhood
at all but did i have a roof over my
head and braces on my teeth absolutely
and do i
do i say that i better off than than
most
children out there absolutely i had i
had a home and i got to go to school
and and i was fed that's huge so i'm
great
sorry for your loss i mean you know when
it's a year it's a year and it's it's uh
uh my condolences goes out to you and
your family but uh
you know there's a movie that when you
were painting a picture it just took me
to
straight to a movie i had my i watched
certain movies with my boys my
nine-year-old and my seven-year-old son
my daughter's four so i don't watch some
of the movies with them
we watched two weeks ago walk the line
and i'm sure you've seen walk the line
you know with the joaquin phoenix and uh
the story of johnny cash
and and you see how johnny in the story
how he had that one
traumatic event with his brother on what
happened there and then how it
haunted him for the rest of his life
until eventually he was freed
and he was able to move on from it most
people don't know everybody's story so
this is why sometimes i wonder if there
is a
connection to a place that if you don't
address that
you're going to constantly be escaping
to something whether your source is
going to be alcohol
sex cocaine pot drugs
ecstasy whatever it may be to have some
kind of an escape
you know and that's one of the reasons
why i was asking the question where does
a person need to go to a
place where you accept your life listen
i've had a screwed up life there's
nothing to be embarrassed up
having said that there's no need to
escape this and if i do there's a
different way of escaping it
so i can move on so does that come first
or is a medicine i need to take to
figure out a way to drop alcohol or
whatever other addiction that i have
that's a great question i my belief is
let's get rid of the cravings
so that you can focus on therapy you
know let's take the medicines
to reduce the drinking so you're
clear-minded you can listen to your
therapist
you can let those feelings bubble over
you you can let the emotions come up if
you're still
drinking actively drinking and
self-medicating with drugs or alcohol
how are you going to grow as a human
being so let's address the biological
issue of addiction
first and concurrently at the same time
work on the emotional reasons and the
traumatic reasons why the person drank
but first we need to get them out of the
state of
being actively in the disease got it
so let's get into the you know different
methods that you had and if you can tell
us more about the sinclair method so
maybe walk us through you know when you
said i tried this i tried that i tried
this what were some of the methods and
then tell us about tsm the sinclair
method
well the first thing i did was what
everybody uh
pretty much said to do is to go to an
aaa meeting and
i you know i have uh i have utter
respect for aaa helping the people it
helped but for me
it didn't do anything it made me want to
drink i mean i'm sitting in a meeting
with a bunch of people talking about
drinking and how it ruined their lives
i still walked out of there with
cravings with with anxiety
um so it didn't i didn't feel gelled and
i also didn't like being called
powerless as a woman i really hated that
i i thought
i thought you know what i'm not
powerless i come from a family of
physicians
i know that there must be something to
fix this i'm not going to
relegate myself to being an alcoholic
for the rest of my life i want to be
able to say
i used to be an alcoholic so this isn't
working for me so that was a a
then i went to a rehab facility where
you know you're locked in a place
with people with everything going on
eating disorders heroin addiction
cocaine
sex addiction poor i mean everything and
we're denied alcohol obviously
and we talk about our childhoods but
then we get out in the real world
there's no preparation for being in the
real world there's nobody telling me how
to identify a trigger
or a what is a a memory how to
a toolbox to deal with with triggers so
you don't drink i mean there was no
preparation for the
world so yeah we're sober when we're in
there but the second you get out you
relax so i relapsed
very quickly after that very expensive
rehab that i thought was bit ridiculous
um then i tried uh psychotherapy so i
went to a therapist who was convinced
that my drinking was
all to do with childhood trauma okay
interesting concept but
no absolutely no appreciation of the
biological aspect of addiction
so she's treating she's trying to treat
this trauma trauma trauma
not knowing that at all talking about it
is just triggering me
once again i'm not given tools to deal
with those cravings or with anything
else i'm just
sent out after the hour and a half of
talking about my childhood
wanting to drink because that's my go-to
mechanism for self-medicating
to not let the feelings bubble so she
didn't prepare me in any way shape or
form
for for triggers or cravings or anything
like that and i'm not blaming her she
wasn't an addiction therapist i should
have gone to
a specialist in addiction the the next
thing i tried was hypnotherapy because i
heard that it helped some people
um that lasted about a week i was like
wow i don't feel like drinking and then
a week later i felt like drinking so
that
only lasted about a week um and every
time i would do an
epis like a expensive hypnotherapy
session it would last
less and less time so it was a week and
then six days and five days
so that um i tried uh
uh oh i tried vitamin therapy because i
was told that i mean i researched and
realized that the brain is lacking
things when you
abuse alcohol that you need certain
vitamin b's
and certain um supplements that will
uh that will help maintain uh
equilibrium
in in your brain so i went into that
whole vitamin thing diet thing
exercise plan and i thought i can do
this holistically
the cravings were still there you know
so i you know
i couldn't change my brain that's
eventually
um i went to my first and only medical
detox in 2009
uh because i was really afraid i was
gonna stroke out i was doing what i
thought was healthy and that was just
going cold turkey
i didn't know about tapering from
alcohol i didn't know that it was really
dangerous to go cold turkey because
every time i would have a binge i'd just
stop i would just stop and go cold
turkey and
recover from the binge well this time
as i was recovering from the binge i i
really started feeling like
i couldn't control my body so it was
really scary because i had heard about
people stroking out
so i called a friend they took me to
this medical detox and it was
once again a horrific experience
experience and on the way out i saw some
flyers
for various treatments for alcoholism
and i gathered them all up and took them
home and looked at them
and one of them said it stops cravings
for alcohol and i thought well that's my
problem
it's the cravings the mental and
physical cravings so if i can just do
that that's great
so i researched it and it was a shot
called vivitrol and i researched it and
there was
a lot of a lot of bad
reviews online and talking about
low-grade depression
and how it doesn't really target the
alcohol uh in a in a
great way so i looked at what the
ingredient was and it was naltrexone so
i googled naltrexone
and up popped this book called the cure
for alcoholism and i was like yeah right
cure for alcoholism but i read it i read
the free
chapter that they had online and i read
it and it seemed really intriguing
so i looked i said you know what i'm
going to try to get this medication i
called my gp and he said
i'm not giving you an opiate when i went
in i made the appointment i went in i
said no it's not an opiate it's an
opiate blocker
he still refused me because he didn't he
had never used it on a patient even
though it's
fda approved it was totally safe it's
proven its efficacy
but at that point it was it was always
um given to an individual
with with abstinence but he wouldn't
even give it to me for that
so i had to order it online so i ordered
the packet of pills from india from a
pharmacy online
which was nerve-wracking and i thought
illegal
and i received those pills after quite a
long time i think i had three months of
sobriety under my belt by the time they
came and i had ordered the book in the
meantime the cure for alcoholism i had
read the whole book i had done some
research
and i thought okay either this is going
to work or i'm going to die because the
next binge is going to kill me because
the last one was so horrific
that you know binges get worse as they
as they come on that's how people die of
alcohol poisoning
and it worked i took that pill i waited
an hour
and i drank maybe a couple of sips of
wine
and i just wasn't interested i tried it
a few more times
my body started getting used to the
medication i started drinking
more like i did in my 20s and at about
the four month
mode uh month i had my what i call my
aha moment i talk about it in my tedx
talk
i was driving down the road and i saw
this billboard
for wine and normally that would trigger
me to want a drink
and i looked at it and my brain said
that's a billboard with a glass of red
wine on it it didn't
have any other effect on me other than
registering what the billboard was
and that to me i was the moment when i
went oh my god i'm
done i'm done with with that obsession
and that
compulsive disorder of my brain i felt
normal
i would go whole days and realize i had
not
thought of drinking that was something
that i hadn't experienced in almost a
decade
wow so to to to there's no other way to
describe it but
to realize on a thursday that you have
not
thought about drinking since you drank
on sunday evening
it makes you want to cry because prior
to that
every day i was either fighting for my
sobriety white knuckling through every
minute of the day
pushing down the thoughts of booze or i
was actively in a binge
so that that was profound and when that
happened to me
i wrote to the editor i mean the um
publisher of the book
and i said listen i want to contact this
man who wrote this because he saved my
life
and they allowed me to contact dr roy
escapa
and i said you know i'm not a big star i
i'm a working actress but
you know i'm not really well known i
have a little group of fans that are
sci-fi
fans that are pretty much worldwide you
know there are millions of people that
love
babylon 5. maybe i could help in some
way
but you know i'm not a brad pitt or
something i'm just claudia
and he said why don't you write a book
and that's
that's why i wrote babylon confidential
and when that came out in 2012 i said
you know what it didn't reach enough
people this is a visual society i'm
going to make a movie so i made one
little pill my documentary
neck 2014. it's available on amazon for
free
if anybody wants to watch it or
onelittlepillmovie.com
and then at that point concurrently i
said you know what we need
a non-profit organization i need to run
it to give
everybody the information that i needed
when i was suffering so they don't have
to
order pills from india and at that point
in 2013 there was one doctor in the
united states
that was willing to use tsm with his
with his patients
one doctor and now today in 2021 the
entire
united states has covered all of canada
all of australia
new zealand most of europe and the uk
it's amazing to have gone through that
process and it's it's almost as if you
did market research for
others who are going through it because
you tried so many different ways
claudia a question for you about you
gave feedback to the person that's going
through it
how to handle it what feedback could you
give to somebody that has a loved one
who is currently at the binge phase and
they don't know how to get out of it
what does a loved one do
to help that person you know transition
out and be free
first of all you you and this is really
hard to understand it's funny
i just did a twitch we have a twitch
channel that we every wednesday we do
subjects and yesterdays was shame and
how important it is for a loved one to
know this is not about
you and that's really hard to do so
when a person says my husband is
choosing to drink over our relationship
you have to eliminate that from your
thought process because
the people who've gone through addiction
this is not a choice
nobody is asked for this to happen this
is not
his fault so let's start there and start
with love and support and say
look i want to help you and i've heard
about this method that involves drinking
it's not an excuse to drink
but it undoes addiction in the brain i
think this would
maybe work for you and i would love if
if you would be willing to try it
and let's watch one little pill so you
get an idea of the science behind it
that's why i made that movie so loved
ones can sit down with the person who's
suffering and say look i'm not judging
you
i'm just excited about this thing i
heard about are you willing to watch
this documentary with me
and if you are interested in doing tsm i
will help you
that's a loving way a supportive way of
saying to a loved one
i recognize you're in pain just like you
told your friend i recognize you're in
pain
and i don't know what to do for you but
i'd love to
learn about this method it might help
you
and then do it together if they if
they're coherent enough at that point to
watch the documentary
watch it with them if they're not you
watch it on your own
go to c3foundation.org look at our free
resources
this person can get as much or as little
help as they need
they can join free online meetings
there's a whole community out there
people on the sinclair method
there's literally thousands of people
all around the world that
that do meetings that have a forum
facebook pages
this is not something new or unproven
this is you know naltrexone's been
around since the early 90s
used for alcohol use disorder but it's
only within the last
maybe decade that doctors are realizing
it's better used
in a targeted manner that means taking
it an hour before you drink
so if you're in the uk by the way and
you or europe and you get nalmaphine you
have to wait two hours but that's a
whole other subject there's two drugs
that treat this
now mephene and naltrexone in the united
states you're bound to get you are going
to get naltrexone
and it has many different generic brands
of naltrexone so you might get
rivia you might get no dick it's all 50
milligram naltrexone for treating
alcohol use disorder
so people can find a provider on my page
they can they can find whatever they
need
so for loved ones we also even have a
loved one for loved ones facebook page
so they get the support they need
most important thing to do is no
threatening right that's a great page
yes we have a we have a facebook page
just for loved ones because that is a
whole
to watch your loved one killing yourself
is unbearable
yeah and i have people say i don't
understand why my son just can't quit
it's a reflection on the parent if the
child
is not doing well and so all sorts of
things come in
ego embarrassment shame my daughter's an
addict my son's a junkie you know all of
these words that we hear it's it's
mortifying for the parent
so they they react quite often with
anger and
one thing that i can attest to that
doesn't work when you're in the throes
of addiction
is anger if somebody's angry at you or
they shame you you're just
more likely to drink more and we don't
want to create that environment we want
to create a really
safe communication line with the loved
one
so we want to tell the loved one you
know just say i know
you're hurting and i want to help you
and i you know i saw this actress
talking about this
here let's watch her ted talk you know
just slowly
bring the idea up and if that person is
motivated to change then tsm
is a great method for them if they're
not ready you can't force them to take
the pill and wait the hour
so this is not a method for somebody to
force on somebody
you cannot force a loved one to do this
this method is for people who've tried
other methods
who other treatment modalities have
failed who are at their wits end
and who are really motivated to comply
with the medication because if you don't
comply
it ain't going to work very very
important topic i'm i'm so thankful that
you came out to uh
share your testimony with the rest of us
i highly recommend
folks you go visit her website we're
going to put the link below as well as
the book you wrote i'll put the link
below a second we'll put the foundation
at the top first claudia i'll give you
the final thoughts here is there
anything else you want to share with the
viewer
uh based on the conversation we've had
today on valuetainment
i just want to say if you know someone
who's suffering or if you're suffering
yourself
please please don't give up this method
works for the majority of people who try
it it has over like an
eighty percent long-term success rate um
when you have
really good care and support it goes
upwards to ninety percent long-term
success rate
so you have a really good opportunity to
get your life back
if you're suffering right now and and if
if it is a loved one
try and employ the methods that we
discussed of being kind and loving
and just giving them the support they
need and giving them
this this information this life-saving
information
that's my last thought on the subject
and i appreciate you having me on here
every single time somebody hears
this spoken about a life is saved
just know that you are saving lives
right now because you know
i cannot tell you how many people reach
out and say oh i saw you on this or i
heard that podcast
you saved my life no you're saving lives
because you're having me on here so i
thank you for that
opportunity oh anytime this is a very
important matter and if we can
collectively uh make it an impact in
somebody else's life we did our part
right so once again thank you so much
for being a guest on valuetainment
appreciate you
thank you take care you probably know
somebody that's dealing with the issue
that she was dealing with everybody
almost knows somebody that's dealing
with alcoholism or some other kind of
addiction that they have and i've seen
many people's lives being taken due to
not knowing how to
deal with it nor do the family members
and loved ones knowing how to deal with
them
that is going through the challenge
right now so i'm curious to know your
thoughts
comment below and if you enjoyed this
interview i think you would enjoy
another interview i do with
daniel lieberman similar topics
different issues
click over here to watch the interview
and
with that being said take care everybody
bye-bye